Traduttore: Maria Pia Lanfranchi
Revisore: Isabella Boux
Buonasera.
(Applauso)
Qualche giorno fa,
dopo il lavoro
e dopo aver ritirato i miei figli a scuola
mi trovavo, come mi capita spesso,
a una festicciola pomeridiana di
bambini di 5 o 6 anni,
quando, un po' stanca per
la routine quotidiana,
ho avvistato una sedia libera
nei pressi del buffet
e ho pensato di appoggiarmi
un minuto, non di più,
perché queste situazioni
non lo concedono,
e non avevo nemmeno
sfiorato il sedile
quando una bambina che
mi arrivava più o meno qua
mi si è avvicinata
brandendo una spada laser
e intimandomi di lasciarle il posto
perché era suo.
Io, un po' per istinto incondizionato,
mi sono effettivamente alzata
di scatto per lasciarle il posto,
anche perché temevo ci potessero
essere i genitori della piccola tiranna
acquattati da qualche parte
e devo confessare che
per un attimo ho sognato
di sentire pronunciare
una frase
che non sento pronunciare
dai tempi di mia nonna
e cioè qualcosa tipo
"Porta rispetto alla signora"
ma poi, chiaramente,
mi sono guardata e ho detto,
"Non è possibile che questa bambina
pensi che io sia una signora"
anche perché tra noi mamme
ci trattiamo con un modo così informale,
e la moda del giovanilismo è così diffusa,
che persino i bambini
ci vedono come dei loro coetanei.
E vabbé, speravo che magari
almeno qualcuno le dicesse
"Dai non fare l'antipatica, Matilde!"
Ma non è andata nemmeno così.
La bambina ha ricevuto un plauso generale,
con una reazione tipo:
Questa bambina ha
sicuramente un futuro"
mentre io ero sotto lo schiaffo,
sotto la minaccia della sua spada laser.
E da questo episodio è partita
tutta una mia riflessione
e ho iniziato a fare caso
a tante piccole cose di tutti i giorni.
Ad esempio ormai quando salgo
sul tram con i bambini,
noto che la folla si apre
come il Mar Rosso
per far sedere i bambini,
mentre una volta
si faceva sedere la vecchina.
Allora ora, la vecchina
è ormai la zitella gattara, leghista,
che doveva fare
la spesa online e starsene a casa,
invece di farci gli sgambetti col bastone
o col suo malefico carrello scassato,
mentre i bambini, con la loro spontaneità,
con il loro modo di fare contagioso,
sono diventati un po' i protagonisti,
come si vede in questa illustrazione
di Maurice Sendack degli anni 60
[Maurice Sendack, 1963, Nel
Paese delle creature selvagge]
e sono quelli che comandano,
in tante situazioni,
il nostro agire quotidiano.
E mi è tornata alla mente
una frase di mia madre
che poco tempo prima mi aveva detto
"Sono proprio sfortunata perché sono nata
quando i bambini dovevano tacere
e portare rispetto agli anziani
e sono anziana quando i bambini
mettono i piedi in testa ai vecchi."
Io naturalmente
non ho concordato sul momento
perché l'ho presa come
un'offesa diretta
alla maleducazione dei suoi nipoti,
e quindi dei miei figli,
però ripensandoci devo dire che
forse non aveva tutti i torti.
Allora,
questa è una foto di "Piccoli tiranni",
ho iniziato ad andare indietro nel tempo
e ho pensato alla storia del cinema.
Mi è capitato di rivedere
di recente questo musical,
"Tutti insieme appassionatamente"
dove il papà, siamo in Austria
negli anni Trenta, ha un fischietto
e a ogni bambino corrisponde
un suono diverso del fischio.
Lui li chiama e loro si presentano
con un saluto militare
e poi si mettono sull'Attenti
... fantastico!
[USA, anni CInquanta, Mad Men]
Invece in Mad Men,
che è una produzione dei giorni nostri,
una serie televisiva,
i bambini, in questo caso i
figli del protagonista Don Draper,
fanno veramente stringere il cuore,
almeno a noi gente di oggi,
abituati a trattare i bambini
con il rispetto con cui li trattiamo oggi.
Questi bambini non vengono assolutamente
messi a parte di nessuna decisione,
di nessun problema
all'interno della famiglia.
Vengono mandati a letto,
praticamente folgorati con lo sguardo,
e devono già capire che devono
abbandonare la tavola
anche se non hanno
finito di mangiare
e chiudersi in camera perché i genitori
devono bere un cocktail, parlare,
o fumare, o invitare amici a cena,
e la loro unica compagna di giochi
è la televisione.
[Heinrich Hoffmann, 1882,
Pierino Porcorspino]
Ho pensato poi agli esempi che
mi venivano in mente della letteratura
e mi è saltato agli occhi questo libro di
fine '800 del tedesco Heinrich Hoffmann
"Pierino Porcorspino"
Praticamente è un libro
ancora edito in Italia,
è una serie di rime che presentano
delle minacce veramente macabre,
fino alla morte violenta, verso i bambini
che infrangono norme anche semplici
come appunto non tagliarsi le unghie,
come è il caso di questo Pierino.
Qui c'è il confronto tra, sulla sinistra
alcune immagini del classico dell'800,
con bambini
che fanno delle fini orribili,
e dall'altra parte invece
un libro uscito in questi anni
in cui la situazione è
completamente capovolta
e c'è un bambino che viene invitato
ad educare il suo papà.
E' vero che è soltanto uno stratagemma
per far capire al bambino
le norme del vivere civile.
Però allo stesso tempo è eloquente come,
in un caso ci sia il genitore che amputa
le mani del bambino con una tenaglia,
nel libro di fine 800,
mentre ora
il bambino prende in giro il papà
che piange accompagnandolo a scuola.
Mi sono chiesta quindi
che cosa è successo in tutto questo tempo
e in particolare mi sono interrogata
su noi genitori, nati negli anni 80,
sui miei coetanei,
ed essendo io un genitore,
avevo un osservatorio privilegiato
su tutti i tic e le manie
dei genitori miei coetanei.
Ho provato a darmi delle risposte.
Noi genitori, nati negli anni 80,
siamo figli sicuramente di persone
che hanno vissuto sia il boom economico,
che il '68.
In un caso o nell'altro,
credendo noi nella psicanalisi
che situa tutti i traumi nell'infanzia,
pensiamo che i nostri genitori
abbiano sbagliato qualcosa con noi.
Quindi, o sono stati troppo di destra,
troppo consumisti,
perchè comunque sono vissuti
nel boom economico
oppure sono stati troppo di sinistra
troppo comunisti, troppo libertari,
perchè hanno fatto il '68.
Sicuramente, se hanno divorziato,
hanno fatto male a divorziare,
se non hanno divorziato,
avrebbero dovuto divorziare.
In ogni caso
noi vogliamo essere migliori di loro,
e crediamo di poterlo fare
differenziandoci
attraverso dei comportamenti alternativi
che vado ad esplorare.
Cosa succede?
Noi genitori abbiamo paura
perché noi abbiamo fatto dei figli
in un momento di crisi economica,
rispetto ai nostri genitori che invece
li hanno fatti in un momento di crescita.
E i nostri stessi genitori,
compatendoci, aiutandoci,
ci danno l'autoindulgenza per
drammatizzare la nostra condizione
che in realtà è praticamente una delle
condizioni più comuni dell'umanità,
che ora invece viene vissuta, appunto,
in maniera drammatica.
Siamo anche persone famose
per non avere voglia di crescere,
forse perché giustificati, perché siamo
stati a lungo nel precariato
e quindi abbiamo avuto una giustificazione
a voler rimanere sempre "piccoli",
e sicuramente,
un sintomo di questa cosa
è che abbiamo gli stessi consumi culturali
dei nostri figli,
perché guardiamo
con loro i cartoni della Pixar,
leggiamo il libro di Hunger Games,
andiamo al concerto di Jovanotti
coi nostri figli.
Tutto questo fa di noi dei
genitori paurosi,
che si aggrappano a qualsiasi moda,
a qualsiasi tendenza,
pur di trovare delle soluzioni
e delle risposte
a questa condizione che ci fa paura.
E, naturalmente, il mercato ha una
risposta ad ogni nostra paura
in un prodotto:
questo è il parenting.
Dovrebbe significare semplicemente
essere genitori,
invece è diventato ormai un settore
vero e proprio del commercio,
che ci targettizza,
ci inserisce nelle mailing list
e prova a venderci una serie di prodotti
tra i più futili del mondo,
ed è anche una disciplina
che si può studiare nei libri,
si può andare a studiare
anche nelle associazioni,
e si può imparare da dei consulenti
specifici,
e ha anche delle vere e proprie materie,
anche un po' indecenti,
tipo allattamento al seno
o ginnastica del perineo.
Noi non ci facciamo mancare
niente. Ci ispiriamo a tutto,
perché pensiamo che questo faccia di
noi genitori consapevoli e progressisti.
E la consapevolezza è il grande concetto
che è un po' l'amo
di tutti questi nostri comportamenti,
perché pur di rappresentarci
come virtuosi,
noi siamo disposti
a comprare qualsiasi cosa.
In questo senso, siamo anche vittime
del pensiero politicamente corretto
che è molto di moda
e di conseguenza vogliamo rappresentarci
come persone buone e giuste
soprattutto sui social,
e quindi vogliamo essere visibili
sui social
come persone che fanno
tutte le scelte giuste
anche per i loro figli.
Per cui postiamo la foto
non di nostro figlio
che si distrugge di TV per 9 ore al giorno
ma del suo primo vaso fatto al tornio
oppure dei pannolini lavabili
a stendere fuori dal balcone.
Questa immagine
rappresenta la Doula,
che è un'altra di queste mode
che vorrei raccontarvi.
La Doula è una nuova figura, che va
molto di moda tra le neomamme,
ed è una figura presa dalla
cultura filippina.
E' una figura che accompagna
la donna nel periodo perinatale,
allora, questa pubblicità dice:
"Every woman deserves a doula",
io non ne sono così sicura,
diciamo che le nostre nonne
non sentivano il bisogno di uno
spazio dove andare a lamentare,
di un'associazione dove andare
a parlare con le altre mamme,
o a lamentarsi con la doula
delle smagliature
l'unico spazio di cui avevano bisogno
semmai era il rifugio antibombe
anche se erano incinte.
Qui tutta una serie di prodotti
che fanno di noi persone migliori,
e che noi non esitiamo a comprare:
c'è il pannolino di mais,
quindi biodegradabile,
c'è il vello d'agnello che si sistema
nella carrozzina
perché il bambino non sudi, non abbia
caldo, non abbia freddo,
stia sempre alla temperatura giusta;
l'amaca di lino, che invece è presa dalla
tradizione degli eschimesi,
per cui il bambino impara ad
addormentarsi da solo, oscillando;
il libro in fibre naturali,
naturalmente anallergico;
i passeggini alti, perché il bambino
non deve prendere lo smog
dei tubi di scarico dei suv
di altre mamme probabilmente nei suv;
e il passeggino per fare fitness,
perché la mamma possa fare fitness;
c'è poi la fascia, la Lullabelly, che è
questa fascia che trasmette musica al feto
nelle vibrazioni adatte
al liquido amniotico,
e c'è anche una fascia che permette
al papà di sentire i calci del bambino,
una cosa di cui l'umanità non aveva
mai sentito bisogno
però noi abbiamo anche questo.
C'è poi una scuola, la Scuola del Portare,
che è proprio un posto che insegna come
fasciare il bambino alla maniera africana,
che è una cosa sicuramente bellissima.
L'ho fatta anch'io.
Però ormai abbiamo queste mamme
che si riducono a lavorare al computer
8 ore al giorno,
con il bambino
legato nella fascia,
e non contente di aver sudato tutto il
giorno col bambino addosso,
c'è la prolunga per il letto matrimoniale,
perché adesso il bambino
deve fare cosleeping,
quindi deve dormire accanto ai genitori
e perciò l'arredamento per l'infanzia
ha prodotto questa novità,
così la mamma può goderselo, sempre
appiccicato al corpo anche di notte.
C'è poi lo sciroppo alla bava di lumaca,
che naturalmente ci ha convinti subito,
perché è omeopatico e non sovvenziona
le terribili case farmaceutiche,
quindi sembra fare schifo
ma in realtà è una cosa bellissima,
e lo spazio per la poppata libera
nei musei e nelle fiere,
perchè, naturalmente,
a una settimana dal parto,
noi vogliamo fare
le svedesi della situazione
e andare a vedere
la mostra al museo.
E poi quella che vedete qui è la grotta
del sale, un posto pieno di sale
che serve a far sgocciolare
il naso del bambino,
proprio come succederebbe al mare,
però costa molto più della casa
al mare l'abbonamento a questo posto.
Per le allergie c'è il test kinesiologico,
quindi un test non invasivo.
Le mamme ormai sperano un po' che
il figlio sia allergico al glutine
perché è questo nuovo
grande nemico comune
e quindi bisogna fare
il test antiallergico.
Ma, per non fare quello tradizionale,
invasivo con le lamette,
si può semplicemente appoggiare sul
muscolo l'allergene e il muscolo,
che secondo la medicina cinese conserva
tutta la memoria della storia del corpo,
risponderà e dirà al kinesiologo se il
nostro bambino è allergico a qualcosa.
Le mamme che vanno dal kinesiologo
e dall'omeopata,
naturalmente
non fanno il corso pre-parto,
ma lo yoga in gravidanza,
e imparano anche il canto tantrico,
che è un canto
che si può fare durante il parto,
praticamente una sorta di gorgheggio
che poi uno non riesce mai a fare
quando partorisce,
ma se riesce,
sicuramente lo staff medico lo odierà
al punto da non somministrargli
l'epidurale, penso.
(risate)
Con questo, volevo farvi sorridere
dei nostri tic, delle nostre manie,
o se non siete genitori,
delle manie che sicuramente
avete riscontrato nei vostri amici,
che compulsivamente
postano foto dei loro figli sui social.
E non voglio dire
che dobbiamo rinunciare
a tutti quelli
che in realtà vi ho fatto vedere
che sono sicuramente dei progressi,
delle conquiste che abbiamo fatto.
La mia riflessione è solo che molto spesso
per differenziarci dai nostri genitori
in maniera virtuosa,
abbracciamo anche delle pure mode che
non hanno nessun fondamento scientifico.
Perciò questo aderire
in maniera entusiastica
a tante pseudo-scienze del bene
che ci fanno apparire buoni,
qualche volta non funziona
perché moltiplica le fonti di sapere
in maniera confusa,
ma soprattutto tende a formare
dei bambini ultra-coccolati,
che non sono in grado
di affrontare niente
senza tutto il kit per la vita
di cui noi li forniamo
e che non sono capaci nemmeno di
passare un'ora
se non sono impegnati nel laboratorio
di cucito o nel workshop di cucina.
Le mode della puericultura peraltro
cambiano molto velocemente
come la moda scarpe, per cui se hai un
figlio nato nel 2005
ti hanno detto che devi farlo
dormire in camera sua.
Se è nato nel 2007 invece deve
dormire accanto a te.
Perciò noi dovremmo avere la saggezza
di informarci naturalmente su tutto
senza però aderirvi completamente,
ma lasciando spazio
al nostro senso critico
e al nostro istinto,
che sotto palate di
sensi di colpa e apprensione,
sopravvive persino in noi genitori nati
negli anni '80.
La conclusione qual è?
Non dovete andare a casa
e gettare i pannolini di mais
nè dare uno schiaffo a vostro figlio
perché forse un giorno non ha fatto
sedere una signora sull'autobus,
ma ricordare che il parenting,
in questa sua versione
commercializzata e narrativizzata,
può sembrare
uno sport molto più estremo
del semplice e universale
e naturale essere genitori.
Grazie.
(Applausi)